nope follow me just one second now right
hey whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa run run run
run run run what's going on my ex-wife
tammy is back yeah i saw her in the
courtyard no my other ex-wife tammy
tammy juan i have accrued 228 personal
days starting right now i'm using all of
them
while i'm gone you're in charge
also
i keep a sizable supply of ground chuck
in my desk remove it or it will begin to
smell
godspeed
ah jeez
oh oh this is one of my greatest
brainstorms ever a community garden
right in the middle of the pit
we're encouraging people to just come
out and plant whatever they want and tom
and i sometimes get here early and help
out
it's so hot i had to get some more iced
tea
people have just really embraced this
and planted the coolest stuff and tom is
our master horticulturist he knows all
the scientific names for everything
right tom yup like this what's this tom
um those are of course tomatoes or
soulja boy tellers whenever leslie asked
me for the latin names of any of our
plants i just gave her the names of
rappers
and those over there uh those are some
ditties some bone thugs and harmoniums
right here growing beautifully those
ludicrouses are coming in great look
someone planted something new what's
this
what do you think carrots if that's true
we have a garden past on our hands
maybe some kind of spice yeah you know
leslie the best way to figure out what
kind of spice that is is roll it up into
a joint and smoke it
well tail whale tail she's flashing a
whale tail abort abort hello
tammy oh
hello ron
i didn't see you come in
i was just checking myself for scoliosis
and straight as an arrow
just like somebody else i know
jerky
call off the dogs you and i both know
that in my entire adult life i have
never checked a book out of the library
oh my god she's amazing
[Laughter]
i admit there was a time when that sort
of behavior would have driven me wild
but i am in a healthy relationship now
tammy a relationship with whom a lovely
intelligent self-possessed pediatric
surgeon named wendy sounds like a real
[ __ ] clear the late charges and cut the
crap
good day
good day leslie good
good day
hey ben just a few things to remind you
of home love leslie
ah waffle mix jj's diner mug new pajamas
wow there's a lot of stuff in here
box one of 12.
april here's something to help you
remember our three-legged dog champion
oh that's cute also you are way better
at laundry can you please do mine and
send it back to me thanks love you
mouserat rules love andy less cute p.s
please hurry i've been wearing a bandana
as underwear for three days now look
there's a picture
ah
that's horrifying
i love him so much
well this is like a waking nightmare of
happiness um i need to get some flowers
uh why don't you hold this colorful
bouquet of highlighters rice i i need to
find some rice i need to throw some rice
why is there no rice in this municipal
government building i found a justice
guy these are the marrying people this
is carl hello carl my fiance and i would
like to get married right now right here
haven't i done a quickie wedding for you
before it's certainly possible but this
one's going to stick i need your full
names for the license ronald ulysses
swanson
diane tammy lewis
tammy you're middle name i'm kidding
it's elizabeth
let's go carl hey hey let's pump the
brakes carl okay belay that order carl
shortest possible ceremony i'm tired of
not being married to this woman do you
ron swanson take down to
yes i do she said yes okay
are the power vested in me before you
carl just one second i would just like
to give a short speech if i may you have
10 seconds
at first glance it may seem as though
ron swanson and i have nothing in common
but webster's dictionary defines friend
thank you leslie
i could tell where you were going with
that it was gonna be beautiful i now
pronounce you man and wife
yay
great job everyone the reception will be
held in each of our individual houses
alone pretend this is rice
that was beautiful oh my god
it's pretty great having andy working in
the building the guy is so much fun his
new thing
piggyback rides
anytime you want piggy back piggy back
move
pick it back bam pick it back bam
mark
brand dang a woods
giddy up giddy up
oh
councilman hauser hello
hello did you get my proposal for the uh
possible rezoning of lot 48 i uh have
been busy i know but i think it would be
a really great thing for the
neighborhood
i don't doubt it but it's really a
question of resource allocation and i
completely understand that but you and i
both know that if we want to find the
money we can
i'm running late oh i'll walk with you
see the thing is when we allocate money
for parts
oh babe you've gone crazy the only thing
i am crazy about is a magnificent
pregnant manta ray named anne perkins i
am ranking topics of conversation for
our next phone call the worst part about
your best friend living in another
stupid state is the topics really pile
up what do you think should be a higher
priority infinity scarves or whether or
not it's worth it for me to get show
time is this really necessary when she
moved we promised each other that we
would talk every day and we've really
fallen behind i know your female friends
are very important to you but i'm always
a good sounding board i mean i can talk
about
sandra bullock skirt length no no babe
you can't you would just embarrass
yourself plus every time i start talking
to you five seconds later i want to jump
your bones oh let's do that instead see
that's what i'm talking about
yeah okay
okay okay ron enough's enough let's talk
plans for diane's baby shower dear god
woman three main activities baby bingo
baby food tasting and my personal
favorite baby onesie decorating station
i want to make mine look like an
astronaut what are you doing up there in
space baby oh so cute okay i have some
gift ideas i was looking at a very
adorable stroller we already have a
stroller oh shoot really i have to think
of something else
oh my god whose baby is that that would
be mine guys get in here run as a baby
oh ron cool maybe thank you andrew
everyone i'd like to introduce you to my
son
john middle name redacted swanson john
was born some time ago weighing multiple
pounds and several ounces much like his
father he is a fan of silence please
keep your voices down how am i supposed
to keep my voice down when you had your
baby and you didn't tell me that you
hate your baby why would you need to
know something like that why would i oh
my god
i have not even sent diana gift she's
just walking around wondering why i
haven't sent her a gift yet should we do
something just let her tire herself out
if you need anything from us around
please just let us know actually there
is something could one of you please
stop by the pet store and pick up some
fish food for me
when did you get a fish
are you ready
yes no babe
are you ready
yes i got fired from running the
sweetums foundation thanks to me sorry
again hey blessing in disguise i took a
job at this accounting firm they've
tried to hire me three times i finally
gave in but i've had a week off in
between jobs and i've been cooking up
something pretty big the last time he
was in between jobs he got deep into
claymation so this should be
different hopefully
presenting the cones of dunshire a brand
new gaming experience eight to twelve
players two wizards a maverick the
arbiter two warriors a corporal and a
legend now the legerman just keeps score
and he wears
this hat oh boy now the object is to
accumulate cones four cones wins but in
order to get a cone you have to build a
civilization the other amazing thing is
the challenge play actually let me tell
you more about the trivia cards because
you're gonna need to know about
roadblocks first never mind think about
the challenge play is it's basically the
game
in reverse then you roll three dice to
see how many dice you roll with oh 16.
perfect lots of choices okay each turn
goes roll by action i mean obviously
this would be much taller in the real
game but the corporal can veto it should
be green too how did this happen are the
cones a metaphor well yes i know what
what what is this called again
the cones of denshire oh my god the
maverick should be able to trade lumber
for agriculture credits how have i not
thought of this before
this is nothing right um when do you go
back to work again tomorrow it's fine
i'll just throw this in the garbage
you